salud en directo américa de france 24 me
acompaña en el estudio marina a sardina
marina buena mañana de juez vamos a
hablar de una problemática bien dura es
el hambre los efectos sobre nuestra
salud cuando faltan 8 años para lograr
la meta cero de naciones unidas- la meta
que se propuso naciones unidas- la
inseguridad alimentaria y todas las
formas de malnutrición siguen creciendo
a nivel mundial y pareciera que esta
meta no la vamos a poder lograr
lamentablemente así es raúl buenos días
el hambre la malnutrición o la falta
hago el acceso a los alimentos se cobran
mil millones de vidas cada año y tiene
unos efectos de largo alcance en nuestra
salud la desnutrición y la falta de
acceso a dietas saludables es por lo
tanto un tema de salud pública como
decías lograr era lograr el hambre cero
para 2030 es uno de los objetivos de
desarrollo de naciones unidas pero lejos
de lograr esta meta la inseguridad
alimentaria la alimentaria aumenta y el
hambruna cada año entre 700 y 800
millones de personas están padeciendo
hambre en todo el mundo como vemos aquí
sólo en y k latina y en el caribe según
el último informe informe de la fao en
2021 el número de personas con hambre
creció en más de 4 millones y hay unas
50 y 66 millones de personas en
situación de hambre en la región una
cifra agravada por la guerra de ucrania
y por la crisis alimentaria que generó
esto no estos representan en el total 18
6% de la población mundial y regional
perdón y un 7,4 en el total mundial en
latinoamérica cuatro de cada diez
personas viven con inseguridad
alimentaria un concepto que engloba la
malnutrición la desnutrición el hambre y
la pobreza extrema y que naciones unidas
lo define como la probabilidad de una
disminución drástica del acceso a los
alimentos oa los niveles de consumo
debido a riesgos ambientales sociales oa
una reducida capacidad de respuesta en
la región también raúl el caribe es la
subregión que representa la mayor
proporción de población afectada por el
hambre haití tiene casi el 50 por ciento
de su población en situación de hambruna
venezuela nicaragua guatemala o ecuador
marín y le pregunto las enfermedades que
derivan del hambre y también de la
inseguridad alimentaria y aquí tenemos
que separar dos conceptos la
malnutrición que es una alimentación
desequilibrada y la desnutrición que es
un déficit de nutrientes que conlleva
esta malnutrición se considera que la
malnutrición es uno de los factores que
más contribuyen a la carga mundial de
morbilidad
la malnutrición es por lo tanto una
carencia de vitamina por ejemplo
vitamina de anemias nutricionales y
tiene prevalencia en la mayoría de los
países del sur global más de una tercera
parte de las enfermedades infantiles se
atribuyen a la desnutrición donde los
factores socioeconómicos se agravan pues
muy potencialmente esto siendo los
menores de entornos rurales de hogares
empobrecidos los más vulnerables una
ingesta insuficiente de nutrientes o una
alimentación poco saludable
la inseguridad alimentaria también
retrasa el crecimiento y socava el
desarrollo físico y cognitivo de los
menores aumentando también el riesgo a
morir por infecciones comunes puesto que
la malnutrición debilita sus
inmunológicos una alimentación poco
saludable también predispone a los
menores al sobrepeso y a la obesidad y a
enfermedades no transmisibles como
dolencias cardiovasculares diabetes o
distintos tipos de cáncer en el futuro
las mujeres raúl también son un grupo
vulnerable a desarrollar este tipo de
enfermedades por una mala alimentación y
es que la inseguridad alimentaria está
también atravesada por la brecha de
género y por la inequidad por ejemplo al
acceso de tierras y alimentos sólo en
2019 por ejemplo la prevalencia de
anemia entre mujeres de 15 a 49 años
aumentó un 30% en la población mundial
además según varios estudios esta
inseguridad alimentaria agrava problemas
de salud mental que siempre quedan como
relegados pero según varios estudios
aumenta por ejemplo el riesgo a padecer
estrés o ansiedad esto es lo que dijo la
organización mundial de la salud al
respecto
raudo conflicto la sequía los conflictos
el cambio climático y el aumento de los
precios de los alimentos el combustible
y los fertilizantes
contribuyen a la falta de acceso a
alimentos suficientes el hambre y la
desnutrición suponen una amenaza directa
para la salud pero también debilitan las
defensas del organismo y abren la puerta
a enfermedades como la neumonía el
sarampión y el cólera mls en cólera
marina hablemos y otro término la
soberanía alimentaria bueno recibe la
fao habla de inseguridad alimentaria
como panacea para acabar con el hambre
hay otro concepto que vamos a explicar
que es la soberanía alimentaria es un
concepto desarrollado desde hace años
por el movimiento campesino
internacional y lo define como el
derecho de los pueblos las naciones o
las uniones de países a definir sus
políticas agrícolas y de alimentos sin
ningún camping frente a países terceros
la soberanía alimentaria organiza la
producción y el consumo de alimentos
acorde con las necesidades de las
comunidades locales otorgando prioridad
a la producción para el consumo local y
doméstico proporciona también el derecho
a los pueblos a elegir lo que comen y de
qué manera quieren producirlo este
concepto reconoce también los derechos
de las mujeres campesinas y exige el
acceso universal a la tierra al agua a
las semillas a los recursos productivos
así como a un comercio internacional
justo estas son algunas de las
recomendaciones de los organismos para
paliar el hambre y por lo tanto las
enfermedades que se derivan de este
hambre y de estas malnutrición es que
pasan por reducir por ejemplo el costo
de los alimentos nutritivos y aumentar
la asequibilidad asequibilidad a dietas
saludables así como lograr la soberanía
alimentaria de las comunidades locales
bueno marina una meta no fácil de lograr
esperemos que cada día nos acerquemos
más a lograr esta meta de hambre cero
que se propuso naciones unidas- gracias
como siempre por toda la información de
salud mañana